commence avec la réaction question de
sylvie 2 sur lefigaro.fr vous êtes le
représentant spécial de la france
enrichissez emmanuel macron à sauf
erreur qui vous a confié cette
responsabilité site vidéo se demande
pourquoi il faudrait traiter
différemment la russie que d'autres
régimes autoritaires comme la chine par
exemple observer la russie était un
grand pays européen
elle a été l'allié de la france au cours
des deux conflits mondiaux
nous avons des coopérations qui ont été
lancé par le général de gaulle et qui
continue à fructifier l'un des secteurs
de pointe
je pense à l'espace à l'aéronautique
je pense à l'atome et il y en aurait
bien d'autres
par conséquent il faut prendre la russie
pour ce qu'elle est un grand pays et non
pas l'hyper puissance qu'elle a été
c'est fini et je pense que il ne faut
pas tout crainte de la russie il faut
pas non plus tout attendre il ya deux
erreurs qu'il faut éviter
mais la russie fait partie de la grande
famille des peuples européens et un jour
on nous avons repoussés vers la chine
par des sanctions mal pensé un jour elle
pensera peut-être à revenir vers
l'europe
c'est cela qu'il faut préparer c'est
cela que emmanuel macron avait à
l'esprit quand il a invité les maires
poutine à brégançon